But we want to thank you for coming out to show your support.
We are fighting a battle there inside and illegally.
But it doesn't end there. It still continues.
We are confident of the arguments we have put forward before the court
and we respect the court
for them to give us an opportunity to explain ourselves.
That's what the electoral Court is meant for.
And then we are there. We are explaining ourselves
and we are asking for the court to listen to us
with cogent legal arguments
which have been adopted
to guide the electoral system in the Republic of South Africa,
of which the a N. C.
Is not immune in itself. As a political party,
it can argue those particular arguments.